Owner of there or not.
I met a burner.
Hello.
I can fit my boner in there too,
which is good.
Most burner phones come with boners
the burner phone.
You get a boner and then,
yeah,
uh,
I,
it's,
it's a great,
it's a great vehicle.
Like I said,
my kids love it.
Mugsy and scooter and sluggo and that you got it because he can't track you with
it.
And also they can't,
let me ask you this.
This is a tough one.
I want to ask you to conspiracy one's,
but this one's a tough one.
Michael Hastings,
you know his case.
Do you know the story?
Yeah.
What do you think happened there?
Well,
let's,
let's explain what happened.
What,
who he was,
he was a journalist.
He was embedded in,
was it in Iraq during the,
um,
during the war he was writing a story for the role for rolling stone.
And he was writing about which general was it done?
Um,
crystal.
Crystal.
Yeah.
So he wrote this story and apparently while this happened,
the Iceland volcano went off.
So they,
they suspended air travel.
So he was stuck there far longer than he was supposed to be and people got
comfortable with this guy being around.
Right.
And so they behave the way they behave.
They made some jokes about things.
Yeah.
He apparently made some jokes about Obama.
This guy put this,
Michael Hastings put all this stuff in rolling stone.
Um,
it wound up being a huge scandal.
Mcchrystal had to step down and there was a lot of people that hated that guy
and a lot of people loved McChrystal and he was a highly respected general.
Yeah,
absolutely.
He had a step down from his position and next thing you know,
x amount of time later,
this guy drives his car 150 miles an hour into a tree.
It blows up.
The engine goes flying in the whole deal.
Uh,
the conspiracy theory was that there was a way,
cause he had a brand new Mercedes,
there was a way that they could take over the controls of your vehicle,
the acceleration,
the braking steering,
and they could do all this remotely.
If they put something in your car,
like we were talking about,
if you could get ahold of this television,
you could turn that television to a receiver.
Right.
Do you think that is possible that someone could have gotten a hold of his car
and made him suicide himself?
Uh,
two points to it.
one is,
is it possible that you can take control of a vehicle,
a modern vehicle?
Yes.
Not right now.
Not the woody,
not woody.
Yes,
we call it.
Um,
but,
uh,
so yes,
it's absolutely possible that you can take,
there's no two ways about salvation steering everything.
Yeah.
If you've got,
and,
um,
and I mean,
think about people should think about,
they think about the,
the Onstar or think about the ability for your car to send data to the,
to the vehicle manufacturer,
right?
Right.
To tell them you know,
what's going on with your vehicle.
Um,
that's a,
that's a handshake operation,
right?
Once you do that,
that that means there's an exchange of information.
What does that mean?
Well,
that means you can access,
can you access that information?
Sure.
Of course you can.
Does that mean you can then take physical controls short?
That's it's,
it's,
it's just another iteration of the exchange of information,
right.
Software can take control of physical systems and so that,
yeah.
So the first part is yes.
Is it possible that that car could have been taken over?
Sure.
Do I think that's what's happened?
I have no idea.
I really don't.
Of course,
but,
um,
it's,
it's certainly a possibility.
I mean,
when I hear people talk about,
you know,
certain conspiracy theories,
I looked at it and go,
there's just no fucking way that can happen.
Like what one,
one d say no fucking war.
Uh,
actually no,
I have a hard time thinking of one.
Um,
uh,
I liked that the theory that with every burner phone you get a boner.
That's,
uh,
I just,
I can't imagine that could happen,
but it sounds good.
I think I'm misunderstood.
What I'm saying is you get the burner phone because you have a boner already
trying to get rid of that.
Oh,
I didn't see the owner.
Now I get a,
yeah,
I got the priorities wrong.
Okay.
So,
uh,
until you secretary to get a burner phone to meet her at the old
hotel.
How,
Oh man,
just like Jeff.